new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new
new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new
new new new new new new new new new new new new new new And this is just what we're going to be doing over the next 25 minutes. So first of all, just to kind of make sure that we all know each other, I'm Laura and I'm the Project Manager. Great. Do you want to introduce yourself again?
I'm David and I'm supposed to be a industrial designer. Okay. I'm Andrew and I'm a marketing expert. I'm Greg
and I'm a hugeurnt face. Great. So we're designing a new remote control. Oh, I have to record he's here actually. So that's David, Andrew and Greg, isn't it? And you're alive, don't you? Yes, we designed a new remote control. As you can see, it's supposed to be original trendy and user -friendly. So that's kind of our brief that we are. And so there are three different stages to the design. I'm not really sure what you guys
have already received in your emails. What did you get? I just got the project announcement. Yeah, that's that. So
everybody got, okay. So we're going to have like individual work and then a meeting about it. And repeat that process three times. And at this point you get to try out the whiteboard over there. So you get to draw your favorite animal and sum up your favorite characteristics of it. So who would like to go first? Very
good. All right. So this one here, right? Okay. All right. My favorite animal is like... How big go? And... The favorite characteristics of it? Is that right? Yeah. All right. Well, basically, high priority for any animal for me is that they be willing to take a lot of physical affection from their family. And yeah, they have lots of personality and be fit and robust good health. So this is BlueBeeGo. My family's be go. Right? Lovely. Lovely.
Well, my favorite animal would be a monkey. And then the small cute and furry. And when plant needs becomes real, and when they're up they're with them. Thank you. You can take as long as this is you like
because we haven't got an awful lot to this business. What we do, we do. Don't feel like you're in
a rush anyway. I actually told you a whole lot more about Beagles. I'll have to get you up again. I don't know what mine is. I'm going to have to think of a spot. Impressionist. Is that a whale?
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I don't know. It's just the first animal I can think of to top of my head. The big reason is because I'm allergic to most animals. I'm allergic to animal for it. So fish was in that for a try. Yeah, and I kind of like wheels. I'm coming in the middle. Everything inside. If I'm
a problemist in my old and interesting. I still don't know what I'm going to write about. Super sketch by the way. I was going to choose a dog as well, but I just wrote a different kind of dog. My favorite animal is my dog at home. That doesn't really look like him actually. He looks like when I can pick actually. I see a dog in there. Yeah. Oh, that's very good of you. No, I see a rooster. Okay. What kind is it? He's a mixture of various things. What did I put him? That's just a guess that his tail works. He's very friendly and cheery and always pleased to see you. He's very kind of affectionate and he's quite wee as well. So he doesn't take up too much space. He does a funny thing where he chases his tail. This is quite amusing. Is he aware that this is his own tail? It is. I think it is. He only does it after he's had his dinner. He just gets up and starts chasing
his tail. Probably when he was little he got lots of attention for doing it. Maybe. Where did you find
this just down here? Okay. Okay. Okay. When I need to discuss the project finance. So according to the brief, we're going to be selling this remote control for 25 euro. And we're aiming to make 50 million euro. So we're going to be selling this one at international scale. And we don't want it to cost any more than 1250 euro. So 50 % of the selling price. Can we just go over that again? Sure. So basically. All
right. So cost like production cost is. 1250. But selling price is that wholesale or retail. Like on the shelf.
I don't know. I imagine that's a good question. Our sale. I imagine it probably is our sale actually because it's probably up to the retailer to sell it for whatever price they want. But I don't know. I mean, do you think the fact that it's going to be sold internationally will have a bearing on highly designed at
all? Yeah. I think it will. Well, right away I'm wondering if there's like the DVD players if there are zones. Oh, yeah. Regents and stuff. Frequency or something. Yeah. Okay. As well as characters, different keypad styles and simply.
Yeah. But for a more controlled, do you think that would be a spousal depends on how complicated our remote
control is? There's no sense that maybe there's a kind of data case. You have more complicated characters than you
would in the money. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And then the other thing international is on top of the price and thinking. The price might might appeal to a certain market in one region, whereas in another, it'll be different. Or
just like in terms of like the world of the country, like how much money people have this band on.
Or just like basic product positioning. The 25 -year -old remote control might be a big hit in London. Might not be such a big hit in Greece. You know. I don't know how to say it's going. Yeah. Mark
it in. Good marketing. I should be writing all this time. Um. Um. Um. Um. Right away, I'm making some
kind of assumptions about what information we're given here. Um. Yeah. Um. Um. Okay. Okay. Does anybody have anything to
add to, um. To the finance issue at all? Do we have any other background information on like how that compares to other. No, actually, that would be useful. Although we're new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new
new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new new
new new new new new new new new new As you point out I just don't think remote control is being something something people consciously assess in their purchasing habits. Yeah, it's just like Getting shoelaces with shoes or something
just five minutes to end of meeting. Oh, okay. We're a bit behind You know what I mean like Sort
of like how do you I mean one one way looking at it would be well the people producing Television sets maybe they have to buy remote controls or another way of maybe people who have TV sets are really fed up With their remote control and they really want a better one or something I'm here in China and
I'm looking for because because I'm a fed -up of having for a five -dimensional course which right right I'm
just how many devices is a control right so in function one of the priorities might be to combine as
many uses Right, so do you think that should be like a man designing in the form of control that you know? I think so dear your satellite and your Regular tally and your VCR and everything well like maybe
what we could use as a sort of like an example of a successful other piece technology is Palm palm pilots They're going from being just like little sort of scribble boards to cameras MP3 players, telephones Everything agenda, so like I wonder if we might add something new to the to the remote control market such as the lighting
in your house or Even you know notes about What you want to watch like you might put in there or I want to Touch and touch and look at that so you can already do it so extra functionality
Like personally for me at home. I've I've combined the audio video of my television set and my DVD player and my CD player So they all work actually function together, but I have different remote controls for each other So it's sort of ironic that that then they're in there You know, they sound everything. It's just one system,
but each one's got its own little Okay, I'm gonna have to wrap up pretty quickly in the next couple of minutes. I'll just check you So anything else anybody wants to add about what they don't like about remote controls they've used what they would really like to be Part of this new one You keep losing them okay Yeah, you get these ones where you can if you like whistle or make a really high pitched noise they beep there I mean is that something we'd want to include you think? I Remember when the first remote control
my my family had was on a cable actually the cable between in the TV and big like buttons It's sort of like like on a blender or something and you know, and I think about what they are now It's better, but actually it's still kind of I don't know like a massive junky thing on the table Maybe we could think about how could be more you know streamline Maybe like a touchscreen or something something like that
or whatever would be technologically reasonable Okay, it could be that it could be that it could be that functionally
that doesn't make it any better But that just the appeal of not having you know these days is every People things of people's homes are becoming more and more like chic, you know nicer material and okay might be
Okay, we're exploring right well So it is to wrap up the next meeting is gonna be in 30 minutes. So that's about about 10 to 12 by my watch so in between nine then As the industrial designer you're gonna be working on You know that's a working design of it. So you know you're doing there For user interface Technical functions I guess that's you know like what we've been doing about what it'll actually do and Marketing executive You'll be just thinking about what it actually what you know what requirements it has to have to fulfill And we'll get instructions email to you I guess Okay Yes, so it's the functional design stage is next I got the little message a lot of seniors my thought I would Before we wrap up just to make sure
we're all on the same page here Do we we're given sort of an example of a coffee machine or We make right now on the assumption that our television remote control may have features which go beyond the television Or are we keeping sort of like a design commitment to Television features. Okay. Well just very quickly because it's
supposed to finish. No, I guess that's up to us I mean you probably want some kind of unique selling
point of it. Okay, so Yeah Okay, right, okay, well that's the end of the meeting then And Thank you
for coming I hope that was what they wanted I Think if you can just leave it on maybe and then oh god this is turned itself Oh Oh Oh I I